[Music]
How is Cristian Cásseres greeting you with
his brief News Now report in
Spanish? I'll tell you that Jesús Javier
Uribe has already been identified as the man
accused of killing a person at a
gas station in the valley. The incident
happened near Jones and is going to  sell
uribe faces various charges including
murder and robbery among others
las vegas metropolitan police say
uribe shot and killed a man who
was inside his vehicle he is
also accused of shooting inside the
store authorities managed to arrest him but are
still  the reason for the shooting is unknown
local real estate agents and real estate agents
assure that the market will continue to
rise in value according to las vegas
Reuters the average for a house is
410 thousand dollars the average prices
for condominiums also rose to 236
thousand dollars this translates to  a 26
percent increase compared to
last year the chocolate factory
will have its garden of lights opened to you and you will be asked
to make a r  eservation also ask for
a donation of 5 dollars to help
tree square
james now dotcom in Spanish for all
the details and we close the week with
warm temperatures as we can
see on Friday we will reach
almost 80 degrees but the temperatures will drop a bit
for the weekend  on
Sunday we can see some clouds in the
valley and don't forget to adjust your watch
as the time changes this weekend
I'm Cristian Cáceres with about the
Spanish broadcast news good day
[Music]